good day everyone
a very warm welcome to this online
webinar titled
crafting experiences stories by
experiential designers from southeast
asia
this event is presented by the society
of experiential graphic design
in partnership with the design singapore
council
and supported by the national design
center
in part one of this series we will be
covering environmental graphics
and wayfinding design
today's webinar consists of mainly three
portions
we will be starting off with a short
sharing by each of our panelists
where they will be talking about who
they are and showcasing
some of their past works following that
we will proceed with a panel discussion
before ending off with a q
a segment where the panel will be taking
questions from the audience
moderating today's session are segd
singapore co-chairs
ola ramanuk and jan foley
currently a creative director of devraj
ola oversees projects in entertainment
attractions
cultural and commercial sectors in
singapore and the region
an avid proponent of taking a holistic
approach to every design challenge
ola believes in meaningful and
purposeful solutions that go beyond the
pure aesthetics
or latest trends she is inspired by
designs that break the mode
whether it is through exploration of
construction methods
innovative space planning graphics or
simply through rethinking everyday
objects
jan folene is the founder of v2
singapore practice and co-founder of v2
architects
in paris he has built a rich
multicultural experience from his
formative years in indonesia
france and singapore embracing
multi-disciplinary
approaches to grow the singapore
practice
has established yarn's diverse expertise
in sustainable architecture
cultural curation and exhibition design
is a frequent speaker on tropical
sustainability
and museum curation in the region and
has been appointed the festival director
of archifest 2018
as well as one of the five curators of
the arts in
transit for the new jurong railway line
in singapore
good evening everyone thank you
charlotte for this introduction
we'd like to thank everyone again for
joining us for segds first
in the series of quarterly talks this
year entitled
uh crafting experiences stories by
experiential designers from southeast
asia today our discussion will focus on
environmental graphics and wayfinding
design
our three speakers joining us today are
esteemed and accomplished practitioners
in the field who have contributed to the
field immensely through their careers
and continue to do so today with us we
have kelly chang
the creative director of the press room
yale new
one half of the creative duo of foreign
policy studio
and william harold wong a william harold
wong and associates
and zhakti so before we proceed to our
main
event with the speakers we're going to
quickly introduce just what
experiential design and what
experiential graphic design
is i'm going to hand it over to young
thank you
sorry thank you allah so welcome again
everyone
we are really happy and very honored to
be with you here
uh this evening thanks again for
designing singapore
for hosting us tonight thanks everyone
for joining
this first series of tone cancer as
mentioned by ola
i will be doing a brief introduction on
what is experiential design so
expansion design in interiors integrates
multiple disciplines to create
a memorable interaction and to enhance
a certain attribute in the overall
experience so experience
comes first and to have a highly a
human-centered approach to
to design so besides functionality
comfort aesthetic and so on experiential
design also addresses
the psychological aspect of human
interaction within
or with the built environment for
example as we can see here
it is impressive to walk into an
aesthetically well crafted hot and lobby
but it is even more inspiring to engage
uh to work into a hotel like when it is
holistically curated from the reception
desk to the guest room
and from the guest service to the room
so to have this highly curated
space so why is experiential design
important
many reasons like the growing dependence
on technological device
is extensive extensively changing human
behavior in day-to-day life
and so it is increasingly more and more
challenging
to create engagement in public spaces
with conventional methods
and that's the reason why we need
experiential
design we need experiential designers
and that's what we'll be talking about
later today in this age of
experience so the five major categories
of experiential design
which one are they exhibition design a
hybrid of storytelling and environment
often found in museums and art galleries
something that is dear to us
or like myself we are also museum
specialists
that's how we met each other as well
we've been collaborating
uh together marketing sensory
experiences like times square in new
york
gabriela marketing and product
experiences and launches
entertainment and with uh of course
things that we are not
experiencing right now in terms of
concert and event but we are all very
much aware of it
place making uh public installations and
landmarks which define the space around
us
and environmental graphics which is what
we'll be talking about
today for messages information and
imagery
now what is experiential graphic
design from experiential design
exponential graphic design
so exponential graphic design involves
the orchestration of
typography color image reform technology
and especially content to create
environments
that communicate so we can say it loud
expansion graphic design is definitely
like communicating with
uh with the rest of the people to have a
message that is clear
that is impactful and highly human
so those are the the important elements
and so the the main category is the core
component
of experiential graphic design signage
and wayfinding
interpretive and place making uh signage
and wayfinding
that we'll be talking about today with
our speakers uh that um
like basically requires more than a way
finding across more than signage
it includes a pathway visual cues
landmarks and so on
to create this mental map of a site or
an environment
and to help people to find their way
through the environment
as simple as that interpretive that's
what we are using mainly
in exhibits this form of like displaying
elements or so to tell a story about the
meaning
of a concept so so that's what
interpretive
uh is for with exponential graphic
design and last but not
least but not least place making
that create a distinctive image for a
site that can be expressed in several
ways
so that's the form of communication a
framework of communication
that is this additional layer to
architecture interior and so on
to make it more holistic one more time
so now i head over to ola to explain to
you a little bit more about this segment
sure so skgd is a society for
experiential graphic design
myself and yan are the co-chairs of the
singapore chapter which we both started
last year
and this is our first event here in
singapore and it really
is to educate connect and inspire the
global multidisciplinary community of
professionals that connect people to
place
and here our goal is to connect these
professionals within the region within
southeast asia
so scgd connects designers that start
in a of fields through graphic design
to industrial design to architecture to
landscape to interactive design and so
many more fields
in fact what makes it so interesting is
that to be
good in uh experiential graphic design
you kind of have to have the skills
in all of these disciplines
communication typography solving
problems
making real physical things dealing with
space and understanding user centered
experience
in interaction design are all part of
this experiential graphic design
so sdgd's goals is to educate connect
and inspire a global community
members are very diverse and include
architects exhibition designers
fabricators
academics students and others who have a
hand in bringing design
concepts to reality the organization was
established in 1973
to share the best practices and raise
professional standards in the field
and today it exists to educate inspire
and connect the global multidisciplinary
community of professionals creating
experience that connect people to place
there are currently 40 chapters globally
encountering with
a cgd singapore chapter that started in
2020
so sdgd educates through workshops
webinars videos
online resources and other events that
provide professional development
and support on topics ranging from
accessibility universal
design to providing documentation and
communication tools
to business development and
sustainability in the practice areas of
wayfinding
place making an identity exhibition and
public installations and research
and strategy and planning there are
design awards that sdgd puts on every
year to celebrate
to celebrate the practitioners uh
globally
and there is also a student category for
the
up and coming designers and students
that are entering the field
sdgd connects uh by producing events for
knowledge
sharing and opportunities to connect
with fellow practitioners
in design and industry the annual sdg
conference is currently the only
international conference focused on
experiential graphic design
aside from there uh there are many other
events that
sdgt puts on annually to benefit the
members
and the community at large
other events that sdgd puts on
engagements such as podcasts sdgd talks
conferences and webinars
and study workbooks
other events uh also focus on
new and cutting-edge technologies
through a series of digitally-centric
x-branded events for example we have
xlab
with new and emerging technologies that
are creating the future connecting to
place
design x which is an annual digital
signage expo
and explorer which provides a digital
foundation's boot camp that gives
designers the
hands-on skills needed to make with
digital
and finally smgd inspires by promoting
and educating about
experiential design nurturing the demand
for design
excellence serving as a source of
education and strengthening
the ties with educational programs that
pervade provide the
academic underpinnings of our field
so if you're interested in joining our
global community or just simply
interested in finding out what
segd is feel free to
email us contact us or sign up at a link
that you see on the screen that you will
see again
at the end of this talk there is a
special membership rate currently for
the southeast asia
region so we hope that the community can
grow here
um segd membership includes a number of
benefits and tools
uh when you become a member you you have
access to the toolbox for a members only
resource of
reference documents directories podcasts
links events rfqs and rfps
salaries surveys and more aside from
that you also get the benefits from
being published on the cgd's website
being invited to speak at certain events
and also receiving discounts to global
award ceremonies
and other events so without further ado
we're moving on to the fun portion of
our talk
so we are also as soon as our speakers
but let's get to know our speakers
before doing this
uh just to share with you a little bit
of this journey that we are in together
so scgd is all about innovation
inspiration and so on
so we all have had this webinar fatigue
for
more than a year now so having something
a little bit more fresh
we'll have three actually four portions
in what we are about to embark on
um so the first one being the fast and
curious
where we'll be having like questions to
our speakers as a form of like ice
breaking
uh moment then followed by a
show-and-tell where the speaker will be
able to show us and tell us a little bit
more of the behind the scene
and then the torque themselves
with the system of 24 slides 24 seconds
a bit like the pecha kucha system uh but
um but it's a bit more because big
picture which is 20 by 20 is 2 is too
fast
so 24 by 24 and then we will end up with
the q a
so
so now we will have the sequence between
like we start with kitty then yanning
and then
william so that's the sequence kelly
yelling
and william so fast and curious
all right kelly just one answer the
faster
as fast as possible so kelly
did you taller manual
morning or night night night time's
neuroman or ariel
i'm still roman
midnight oil or orange oil olive oil
yes we have grown
okay
or in design indesign in design okay
faster pass
life imitates art or art imitates life
i imitate life yes
lauren
and gray scale of color color
ah yes
[Music]
less is more and more
landscape landscape all right
thanks a lot guys so now uh i i head
over to olaf for the show and tell
uh a bit a bit more behind the scenes
and so on so
we have a we have a short questionnaire
for each of the speakers they've seen
the questions in advance
so there will be a short response that
will uh
that they'll have for us in response to
each question
so we're going to start off with kelly
once again
okay i'm ready all right
what is the most used design tool on
your desk and why
let me show you my computer of course
no-brainer all right uh
what inspires you around your design
space
uh the mess the mess around me
wow okay okay looks looks very inspiring
and what is your favorite experiential
graphic design project
in the region it's gotta be the snoopy
museum in tokyo
ah okay okay okay nice all right
thank you cali we're going to move on to
yelling next
all right uh yeah when do you feel the
most
creative in the bathtub oh
okay nice what is the most used design
tool on your desk
and why um actually it's my fountain pen
okay all right and what is the most
unexpected thing or item in your studio
i don't know what's unexpected something
that we
might necessarily not expect that's in
the designer studio
uh i don't know
um maybe it's my hand cream
okay all right beauty products okay
all right thank you last but not least
we have william
all right william are you ready yeah
sure all right william what inspires you
around your design space
um in the office our huge collection of
books
i don't have many books on design but i
focus on
asia particularly southeast asia from
history
symbols textiles anything from
cartoonists to philosophers
in fact sometimes there's the same
person okay
all right thanks william uh what is your
favorite experiential graphic design
project in the region
i think it would be our museum projects
particularly
museum sultan abubakar which i will show
in this forum
okay and the last question when do you
feel the most
creative
i think there's no specific time or mood
of the day
no i just happen suddenly anytime
anywhere i can't explain it
uh that is all we have for the uh
for the get to know you portion of this
talk
so now we can we can finally enter into
the the main course our talk which is
uh which is basically the tool from the
from the speakers
so then thanks again to the three
speakers to be to be with us today and
thanks everyone to
to to to be with us as well so kelly
kelly chang is someone that is very dear
to me um that i met
more than 12 years ago when i arrived in
singapore and she
had she has been personally a true
source of inspiration
uh but that's a just a quick personal
note uh
to to my dear kelly uh so trainers and
architects uh
kelly is the founder and creative
director of design studio the press room
a publishing and design consultancy that
designs
everything from books brands exhibition
documentaries and stage and film set
design
an active educator she has served as
adjunct lecturer in singapore
universities and herself on
international
design judging panels including redhead
award
nagoya too designed for asia a world
creative circle the world gem days in
the world and so on
and in 2021 she was conferred the skills
future fellowship
for her achievement in the industry
presented by the president of singapore
the next accolade will be what the
goddess of
graphic design in singapore
okay uh guys so this is about stories
about uh wayfinding exhibition graphics
design so i wanted to share a few things
about what i experienced
in real life with clients and how these
can usually kill the experience of
wayfinding graphics so it's really the
what not to do
okay so some places are actually meant
for you
to get lost when we were designing a
museum
art gallery uh the client was so afraid
that people would get lost that they won
a sign every like one meter
at some point the architect got a little
bit frustrated because he's going to
destroy his architecture
and he went this is an art museum
this is not a hospital
so one of the strangest requests that we
got is someone want us to put braille
on the directional cyborg it's like
hello
they are blind so if you put braille how
they're going to
know where the signboard is uh unless
you have some visual
uh sorry some audio cues uh that can
lead them there in the first place
so sometimes uh client asks for really
weird things
ah there's one concern that i find very
strange that client always calls to
increase
the size of the handicapped sign on
directional board and for me it's like
they are physically impact not visually
impaired
why do we need the handicapped site so
big
okay and another strange request that i
get all the time is that
when you reach the toilet sign outside
the toilet uh
clients always ask for it to be big i'm
like you're already at the toilet
why does the toilet sign have to be so
big
and uh okay so there is a difference
between destination
site where you mark the destination of a
place those have to be big
and directional sign where it's a
signboard where you list up all the
different places can always say oh make
the phone bigger bigger bigger bigger
but i mean
seriously how big do you want it to be
directional cyborgs are meant you know
if you can't read it you can go closer
okay this this carpark zoning thing why
is it that
we can only use animals and flowers can
we use
other symbols uh can't we be more
creative this is what you hire me for
let's move away from animals and flowers
and okay for um if you hire a wayfinding
expert
you will get the best value if i can
create
as few signs as possible and not the
other way
so clients sometimes think that to get
their money's worth they want us to
create
as many sites as possible but not
everywhere is a frankfurt airport
you know if you've been to frankfurt
airport is the beacon of getting lost
whether it's bad wave finding or is bad
architecture
okay so the other thing is sometimes we
tell clients that you don't actually
really need any cyborgs because you can
create
visual landmarks especially if you're in
a park or in a garden
you know you can create actually
sculptures and it is actually much more
memorable for people to remember their
way
okay so i'm sure a lot of you might have
experienced this before you go to a
shopping mall and then you see the
toilet sign one on the left and then one
on the right
but actually whether you walk the left
side or the right side one it leads you
to the same toilet
that is really confusing so uh in way
finding
design you don't need to give them too
many choices
you as the designer has to be very
decisive
sometimes for me you don't need so many
directional sign all you need are just
some simple
flaw stickers and they are much more
effective
but clients always fear that oh i must
replace them all the time but they are
probably much cheaper than if you make a
really big signboard and actually they
are much more lasting than you imagine
okay so we also always have requests
that they want as well a printed map for
people to carry around to find their way
and so when they ask for a map actually
then they start to include
so much info and it becomes uh quite
silly because
it's like practically carrying a book
around so that's
the other thing that we encounter
um okay there's a difference between a
city map and a
floor plan so uh we have requests before
on
directional cyborg that the client wants
to include the floor plan but it's very
difficult because
if you want it to navigate towards the
direction that you're standing
uh you that means you have to twist the
the map around like almost 360 degrees
a lot of clients think that exometrics
are very nice they always want us to do
a axonometric
uh sort of a plan but unfortunately it's
not very effective because a lot of lay
men do not know how to read an
axonometric
so i don't usually recommend it
wayfinding has to be as simple as
possible
okay so now moving to exhibition design
expedition design
is really about storytelling so you
should make
the presentation as simple as possible
as long as your content is good
you don't want to create a very
complicated uh
sort of scenario where you you confuse
your visitor
a very rich story uh can be simply told
so it's really about how you craft the
story at the end of the day
while exhibition design is about
storytelling it is not a storybook
so people do not want to go there and
read a lot of text they want to go back
and feel it has to be experiential so
sometimes uh we get a lot of encounters
where clients want to include so much
text
and uh it it really is not
not feasible because nobody likes to
kind of like
read uh lengthy words
uh this is a very strange request that
we we get all the time clients
say oh can we not have the text on a
flat panel
for me it's like uh then how to reader
i mean presenting text uh sometimes the
most effective way is still on the flat
panel but it depends on the material you
use the type
or the form that you choose and all that
there are many ways that you can
embellish uh text
okay interactive does not automatically
mean touch screen
a lot of time when they say they want
interactive they usually
think that they want a touch screen but
even if you put a black box
and a chalk there something that the
visitor can just play with
it is as well as interactive as any
touchscreen or any electronic device
so they should kind of truly understand
why it's interactive
okay this is the other problem we
encounter all the time uh
clients think that we need an
illustration for everything
so sometimes it is so literal like put
the headphones on
um do you really need the illustration
for that
okay this is the other thing that uh
that we encounter a lot
um this uh this request for infographic
it's
i don't know it's some kind of a trend
or something uh
clients tend to think that everything
needs an infographic
uh the truth is you you don't you know
uh because some things
can't even really be interpreted into
an infographic okay so uh people also
like to use a video for every single
interview
for me no sometimes you just need a code
of uh
from each person um because if you can
convey something in
one sentence why do you want to use a
video videos are only used
when you can't convey so to end of this
presentation i'm going to show a video
of an exhibition design that i did that
hopefully
does not have all those issues
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you got what i needed
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much kelly it was uh it was
really exciting to see all of this and
really fun and and i think you had a lot
of fun in doing and doing all of your
slides we have
many questions already but we will be
keeping that for
for later so to the audience if you do
have questions
feel free to send them and then we will
be uh
keeping them for the q a session so now
we'll be
like giving that to ola for her to
introduce yelling
yes so our next speaker on the panel is
yelling you
she is the creative director of foreign
policy studio
foreign policy is a brand and design
bureau based in singapore that helps
brands to tell their
stories and craft experiences using
strategy
graphic design and interior design
the creative directors jalen and arthur
are
a group of idea makers and storytellers
and
they're the companies independently
owned and creatively motivated
so yelling welcome and thank you so much
for being here and we're going to
pass the slides over to you thank you
thanks for having me um i guess we can
start
thanks uh kelly for the primer that is
awesome for my
next chapter in in this session
uh i wanted to talk about some projects
that we did and
maybe to show some of the strategies
that we apply on the wayfinding
starting with this project that we did
for sufang art museum that is
in nanjing and it's a relatively small
wayfinding project
that we did in conjunction with the
branding that we
also designed for them and um as
with how we do in the studio everything
has to be
cohesive i mean holistic and
um we wanted to be sure that the
language the narrative and
the brand goes into the wayfinding as
well so
in this case the branding is really very
clean and
because it's a museum we wanted to make
sure that everything is showcased
and not being open designed so we
designed a special typeface
for the chinese and the for the logo as
well as
then it was applied on all the
collaterals as well as
the wayfinding as you can see here in
some of the signages that we've
applied and because it's a really
small museum and it's a very sort of
everything is white uh it was kind of
not so difficult to apply but our
strategy was uh really not to overwhelm
the space because it's small and also
because it's a museum we didn't want to
be seen as the design overtaking
the function of a museum being
the artwork is the most important
element that has to be
first and foremost in the museum so i
think that one is something that we
are pretty happy about in terms of
execution
um the next project that i
want to share is if this slide moves
it's another project that we did as uh
i guess com full project in in branding
as well as applying it to the wayfinding
it's a project in hong kong
a restaurant in the hong kong jacket
club which we had um
sort of a full play with the branding as
well as uh
uniform and because it's um
well the the key dna of the star the
narrative is really about
uh the british uh um the
eccentricity in the british uh colony
in in hong kong that we applied that
style throughout the branding as well as
to the um interior uh wayfinding
uh you know we've got different kind of
signages whether it's
uh directional signages or um
just instruc i guess just toilet signs
and uh
uh destination science they we try to
apply
different various different materials
and and styles to make it a little bit
more interesting for the experience
uh in the restaurant well the customers
uh
the guests are there and we always try
to
explore different ways to express
the different signages such that i guess
in our terms it's cohesive and it's
very i guess in holistic
in the brand storytelling so we will
explore different materials
and different materials and different
ways of combining materials
when we're building the signages as well
as
the graphics for this one it's also not
a huge
restaurant but it was interesting where
we could play with
um a huge wall of graphics uh as well as
the different types of signages that we
can
employ in the space whether it's on the
floor or on the ground or
on the walls and even on the entrance
this other project is a co-working
project called the working capital and
a similar strategy is applied we
love to make sure that uh we wanted to
uh to to make sure that we create uh
unexpectedness
in um way the way finding but yet it's
uh i guess functional as well as usable
especially for this brand where it's
supposed to be a more design
designy sort of coating space so
something
that we uh bear in mind when we were
designing the wayfinding
was to create a different unexpected
way-finding visual cues where people
could find a way and
at the same time it became sort of a
signature and landmark
where people could remember because that
was also a very complex
place to i get designed the wayfinding
because it was a combination of
different sort of
i think five or six shop houses that
were combined together
and i always take interest in designing
the toilet signs
so always try to also just
i guess explore different ways of
expressing uh the toilet size
and uh as as you can see we love playing
with materials so
we would always try to combine different
kind of materials
to express the signages um and i think
for this project it was suitable because
it's a
more creative space that we could play
with
yeah and then colors was important as
well so
we worked with the interior design very
closely as
we also the brand designers so um we
were able to spearhead
the colors and and um
i guess leading the design in that way
such that the wave finding sits
perfectly in the space um not jarring
and yet
interesting we also like to play with
because this is a
creative space we also explored with
anamorphic
signage and this was actually
layers of text that was
i guess painted in different layers but
on
in one angle you'll see them readable
but on the other but you would not
so this was also executed in various
different
locations of the space
including spaces that were not so sexy
we wanted to
still play with it nothing that was left
to nothingness this other project was a
wayfinding project for arab they have a
huge office in singapore that was a
two-layer office that took out the
entire floor and the building
in the downtown area and because it's
such a complex
office well it's complex in the sense
that there were so many people
employees and they needed to find a way
so
we were able to work with them on
developing something that is um
interesting and yet uh usable
uh as as usual i love to play with
target science
um and we've actually employed
various different visual uh elements on
the signages itself uh to make it more
interesting which is what arab wants
um because it was a huge uh space
um there are different different
directional signs
and and uh destination signs that we
need to take care of
and also naming uh i guess designing the
different zones
were really sort of complex and
some of them were identified by
landmarks as what
kelly had said before zoning we
took a strategy of using colors
and i guess using naming it with
some projects that they have worked on
um and and that has
created graphic elements that we could
use to
to i guess create a space in each
zone we were also very lucky that they
were open for us to play with
different materials again um in the
various
signages i think this has been a quite
fun project for us as well because
it's not just uh figuring out where
things should be
there's also a chance to um lead
make direction easier for for the office
using colors and graphics at the same
time and that the client was
pretty open for us to um do to do that
as well
where this is that uh kitchen area where
we
also included uh sort of a
generated um uh bird
figure that the the founder has sketched
on his sketchbook
uh so that was uh also applied on the
wall as part of the
environmental graphics yeah
pretty much thank you for having me
hope you guys uh understood what i just
shared
thank you young that was that was really
great we we appreciate how
uh your creativity specifically in
making the
ordinary signages more playful and
interesting and so
creatively driven so now we're going to
pass on to the last speaker
uh okay yeah so
thanks again
[Music]
and it was definitely like mercy and and
um
and the more we go into this talk and
the more we feel
how immersive all of these experiences
so
it is a very good transition towards
william
and it is a honor for me to introduce
the the the body of work of
freedom so william works at the
intersection of
brain culture city and community
enhancing the human
and cultural experience of a place
he's passionate about southeast asian
culture
thank you that's great because this is
exactly where we are
and has documented the region
extensively in his early years
he also manages zakti a 360 design meat
technology company
with storytelling very important with
storytelling at its core
with partner project offices in dubai
and renee
working on museums galleries and
experiential spaces
william received a lifetime achievement
award
from malaysia and national awards for
mainland china
hong kong and india he's the chairman of
the design
alliance asia and the past president of
ecograda e-codi so it's
it's fantastic to have you today william
i'm sure we'll be
listening religiously to your
presentation
so uh so well let's welcome let's
welcome william
thank you okay i'll give some background
uh in the late 80s and 90s i was very
involved in the local art scene
and have designed many posters and
exhibition catalogs
in 1997 you know tony blair became the
young prime minister of uk
and we were all step up in the
excitement of those times
working on projects to promote uk's
the very beginning of the creative
industries in southeast asia
this is one of our earliest signage
projects it was for kuala lumpur's
first smart building with a tropical
garden at the heart of the city
so we combined technology with nature
and my designer clarissa created this
cookie cutter patterns to represent the
very
large greenery around the building i
really love this project
um our office was on
cab winning road named after the old
community trees in the neighborhood
however like most malaysians i couldn't
tell one tree from another
so when i created the carpark signage
identifying local trees
i was hoping to educate the public
myself included
about the real treasures that live
around us
and this also became the client's
corporate philosophy
or rather it reflected that atrial is a
refurbished uh neighborhood mall
the idea of the malaysian rainforest as
a concept came from the
interior designers there have been of
course many attempts to bring nature
back to the city
not only in landscaping vertical gardens
group gut
rooftop farming etc but also in
environmental design concepts so we look
at the
form the shapes the textures and the
spirit of nature
our toilet signs are like the small
rocks and pebbles in the
forest stream interestingly the clients
project engineer said to me oh now i get
it
that stream of water for the toilets
this is where you pee
i laugh and say it is a very good
alternative original for the signage
atrial is a very very old shopping mall
1985
at that time refining was done with
images of animals like birds for the
upper levels
elephant for meat levels and fish well
you know it's the basement flow
simple and effective i think santa city
singapore had a similar system a long
time ago
but in malaysia the system disappeared
totally in the 80s or 90s
in favor of minimal typography so we
kind of revibrate it
at atrial i always look for
opportunities to
inform inspire to educate the public
and place next to the elevators in the
shopping mall are
really fascinating insight into the
personalities of animals
to evoke empathy and for endangered
species
how we can help them you can see in the
text for the monkey right at the bottom
a reference to wwf and responsible palm
oil
this project is a commercial center in
the midst of a really beautiful township
with lakes parks and walking trails
so i was a bit disappointed when they
saw the very tight cluster of concrete
buildings
in this development there were eight
blocks of building
named a b c up to h
each block had the name for example a
for enson b
for balaami the names were taken from
street names from colonial days to
reflect the
colonial style architecture so i wanted
to introduce images of the flora and
fauna from the surroundings
into this commercial center to life
up what was essentially a kind of
monochromatic gray and white
environment and this is how the building
blocks
name you can look for faraday or
just block f um by the way none of these
ratios was executed due to
budget constraints i think it will only
remain on paper
however i mean thanks to a good client
we were fully paid but
as designers you know that's only half
the point
it's a pretty not to be able to see your
design being implemented
a work in progress the client asks us
whether we can
have each letter support not only the
name but also
a flower animal bird or insect you can
see
an attempt here for d on the top right
d for davidson and dragonfly
but it was a very difficult task because
we only wanted images of nature
found on the premises unless for e
you bring in elephant
this museum was transformed from what i
thought was a sadly abandoned colonel
building
and with a hot tarmac carpark lot in
front of the building which we replaced
with a shallow
water pond and fountain for children to
play
we had a good game and credit must go to
dr parry the museum director
and architects tamiko ro and natsu
nakata
the local we designed comprised of three
iconic elements
of this area the pounding waves of the
south china sea in the center the
banglao
a decorative and even spiritual guard on
the traditional fisherman's boat
and the really exquisite wood carving
tradition
which is found in this region
wood carving is so important to this
region and wood unifies the exterior and
interior of the museum
so outdoors there are driftwood
sculptures of birds and animals found in
the district
the horses represent the towns well
apollo championship
at the time these photos was taken
another important animal to the state
the elephant wasn't ready
i guess it takes a lot of brief wood to
actually construct
an elephant probably take some time
the east coast is really known as the
crater of malay culture
especially with carving and
hair and here the medium uses the medium
of wood again to unify or integrate the
outdoors
with the indoors
this building was originally a residence
and some entrances to the galleries were
very small and hard to find
like the back door of a kitchen we
designed very large posters to draw
attention to these gallery
entrances and to help visitors find them
with ease
because they seem to be quite obscure
from certain angles
the posters also serve to reinforce the
museum's new identity
images of o pahang lying the corridors
giving the visitors
a sense of time and space and place
it was also an opportunity to show the
classic patterns and colors of the
woven cotton or sub fabric called
eternum pahang
which comes from this district there are
many
master weavers at work in the villages
around the museum
so we designed a visual system that
reflected the local traditions
the checkered pattern of this woven
cloth the tanum pahang
is integrated as simple cross lines
this grid or cross line is also seen in
aerial views of the pedophiles or the
rice fields
the bilipis is a bird which is one of
the town stable
i'm not sure whether it actually
whistles it is called
a whistling duck but it certainly lets
out a very high pitched
sound so the same checkered pattern of
the
textile appears on the signage either
engraved or sub-screen on
enclosed on the mat white surface
i chose itc berkeley all-star because of
its association with academia
it was designed by frederick goudy for
the university of california press in
berkeley
and i added ffd to achieve a balance of
tradition
and the contemporary founding fathers
was a book which was launched
with an exhibition at the etihad museum
in dubai
the book featured portraits of the late
president and the late vice president of
uae
as you can see on the right from cover
to cover
but unfortunately the photographs alone
would not be able to sustain the
interest of visitors
in an exhibition so with our partner in
uae we designed the exhibition through
the eyes of the photographer
ramesh shukru who arrived in dubai in
the 80s
and never left i did this sketch on the
plane and good from malaysia to india
it had to be very legible my sketches
are really quite sketchy
so that everybody understands what i was
trying to convey
so the exhibition was really much about
the
photographer and the art and craft of
photography in the 60s and 70s
as much as the founding fathers i wanted
the exhibition to convey certain
qualities
due to this black and white positive and
negative
hidden and revealed and raped the color
of the mock-up
dark room we created for the exhibition
so as visitors were leaving the
exhibition they come across two
interactive wall panels
where they see themselves in negative
color in real time
this is particularly intriguing in the
middle east where men
traditionally wear white and women black
and it's a surprise for visitors to
catch themselves in reverse colors in
fact
many guests were coming close to the
wall and grinning and smiling because
the tit appears black
and rather strange looking everybody had
a good laugh
this small mosque was built in the 1930s
and after two years of restoration it
became the islamic art and culture
museum
it is especially beautiful the light and
columns in this interior in a 1920
travelogue by
chesterton he described the mesmerizing
effect of arabic script and architecture
repeated again and again like ornamental
stars or flowers like the chorus of a
song
indeed one is driven to repeat oneself
about the reputation so that
overpowering is the impression
and we designed information panels to
mirror the extra coordinates as you can
see on the extreme
right bottom adding to the museum's
overall
symmetry and magnifying is repeated
geometry the white interior of the
museum serve as a blank canvas
for the interplay of various qualities
of light i would like to add
a designer ought to leave beautiful
places alone
the layout of the interior is
symmetrical
we were to design the signage but we
concurred with the incline that
there will be no signage for this museum
not even a single sign the transparency
allows one to see through the entire
space
the museum content was divided into
three sections the islamic world the
royal realm and the malay were and the
negation was
actually on the captions itself if you
read the captions
you know where you are and finally with
partners from different design
disciplines we
established exactly a 360 design
neat technology company with
storytelling at score
with partner officers in dubai and
brunei
so the tech team has been working on
server work exposed
including content development and so i
think we will see some very exciting
work ahead for museums galleries and
experiential spaces looking very much
to 2021 and onwards
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much william
for this
very inspiring uh talk with a lot of
meaningful
meaningful elements from from kelly and
highly educational
talk to yelling with her immersive
approach to wayfinding and
and of course william with a lot of
meaningful meaningful approach a
meaningful
project so thanks uh to the the three
speakers today
um into the two pleasure to to to listen
to your talks
and now we can move on to the q and a
session
uh so we receive quite a lot of creative
questions so
together with uh with hola we'll be uh
asking you uh what has been uh
shared with us maybe you want to start
with a question uh
hola so we'll read some questions uh
from the audience that we've been
receiving
throughout this talk the first question
is
for kelly uh hi kelly love your
presentation
any examples of wayfinding design in
singapore that you find the most
effective or your favorite
okay so i i think i think that's
effective and favorite
uh the most effective i think is uh
botanical gardens
uh i love going there it's uh just full
of plants and all that but you
never somehow never get lost or even you
get lost you know it's quite nice
and you are able to somehow navigate in
a very natural
and relaxing way so that's my favorite
uh no sorry that's the most effective
favorite has got to be the national art
gallery right
i'm sure that was a challenging project
in its own because of the
challenges of the architecture and the
history historical buildings and
connecting all the different spaces
yes yes totally in fact jan was uh
working with me for a while in the
beginning yeah
so uh it was very challenging but uh it
was an eight year project
yeah so uh a lot of challenges but i
think we managed to pull through
in a quite uh satisfactory way and
aesthetically pleasing
so yeah so it's good okay but thanks
uh thanks a lot uh kelly um so we have
we have a few questions
um at least two all speakers 12 speakers
um do you have a process to test
to test out your way finding
so you can start with with a video now
how do you test your wifi
well of course with paper mockups uh
we'll do paper mockups not necessary
exercise but if the
spanish more than it can be and we just
have to
ask people to walk around and just
observe it's very simple there's nothing
like a real life test
but then that that's very true in terms
of that when we look at the work of
hyaline for example
how do you do when you do such large
installation
because your your immersive approach to
wave painting how do you test them out
in reality to convince your client for
example
i think it's the same paper mock-ups as
well as
mock-ups but well we have to work with
the contractors to help us with
some form of actual basic markups
i guess to for us to see whether it's a
feasible
um identifiable uh
signage uh at a certain distance and
then when it comes to graphics it's
really just something we have to show we
can only show
sometimes on the computer which is not
the best but
um yeah and we
also sometimes employ
technology to help us to to uh navigate
well to help the client navigate the way
they could
to to i uh to imagine how the space and
the signage could be would be
a vr
yeah a system that we try to test out on
but not always
yeah okay and then for you kiddies it's
the same
paper mockup and like 3d representation
uh uh yes and also so i i usually look
at it in two
two parts yeah so we have the way
finding strategy which is quite
different from the wayfinding graphics
so in terms of the strategy uh we
usually try to kind of like test it out
on floor plans you know you mark out all
the intersection points and all the
keynotes and all that and you build the
hierarchy
uh it's actually very complex and
sometimes in all honesty in terms of
wayfinding strategy
you can't be 100 correct and uh and it's
a
even after the the signs are put up it's
a little bit of the testing process
and then before the place is open you
know you walk around the rail space
and you decide if you want to add some
additional graphics that's the way to go
for strategy
in terms of the graphics itself as with
uh what william and yaling has said yeah
we actually get the contractor to print
out exercise
in uh full full size and then we we test
it
we place it on the wall and all that and
then we check distance and all that
uh for every single different panel
every single different hierarchy
we relay all out and then we check it in
terms of visibility
so these are two different things yeah
okay okay
good thanks a lot the next question is
for
how do you craft the story for each
project in the unique
angle and how do you determine uh what
are the key characteristic elements are
out of the many
others well some projects are
projects that we um we'll be working on
a brand
brand identity for so i think that's a
really
easier angle to to work with once you
have
established that through branding um the
other
other projects would be you know
projects that
would not require a brand or other
you know branding identity but a
solely singularly um wayfinding
project for those kind of project i mean
whichever route that is
uh it's always uh for us to find out
the dna and the essence of what the
company or the space is about and then
from there we
could then uh sort of like single out
what are the
key stories that we want to tell i mean
there are different ways that you can
we can approach anyone can approach
designing
or you know designing a narrative um
for the space so uh i guess it's a
decision that needs to be made
um then and then so yeah depends
sure sure you understand yeah yeah it's
um
okay we have many questions arriving and
uh and there is one in particular
um that is related to the discipline
itself
um is there any
like particular school towards
environmental design is there any school
of design in our region
especially singapore malaysia where
environmental
design environmental graphics is being
taught
if yes which one are they and if not how
did you
like how have you how have you been
educated
about that if it wasn't in school
so maybe because i'm with william i
don't think so because i think now it's
a i think we have to really look at
uh design education because it is
becoming very multi-disciplinary
and i don't quite how i don't quite know
how
you know uh when design disciplines are
studied in silos uh how could they
actually come and collaborate together
so i think that is a problem in malaysia
at least in my country i know that
and also i know that in fact she is
actually among your audience i had a
intern from student intern from
netherlands about
wow 20 years ago and she came from in
harvard
and it was truly multi-disciplinary it
was really
the students didn't really choose a
topic graphic design
or interior design but rather choose on
what the student's passion is so it's
divided into
transportation into entertainment
and so on and they learn all the
disciplines within that group
under the industry that was quite
interesting experiment
at a very specific point and that we can
really see in all of your practices here
that
you are definitely multidisciplinary
uh by a sense like intervening in many
different aspects of
of experiential design and we can really
see that whether it is
wayfinding or exhibition design uh uh
environmental but it's by itself so so
that's something that is
true to to your practice
to be a multidisciplinary um
i think we have other questions so we
have we have quite a lot of questions
which is which is very exciting yeah
we have a lot of interest from everybody
and then everybody's curious about
sort of starting from your work cross as
to how do you deal with challenging
situations
so um one of the things that's probably
not specific to
environmental graphics or wayfinding but
maybe it is
um how do you specifically deal with
phases of creativity block
and feeling burnt out in this industry
so i think this is a question for
everybody um maybe uh we'll
we'll we'll let whoever feels the most
passionate about this
respond to the to the question
kelly yeah
you have something to say yes you feel
like you're we feel like you're holding
back
i mean a quick honestly creative burnout
is unavoidable especially for
for some of us who have been practicing
for decades uh you know it gets
a little bit tiring so uh i mean the
only way
sometimes for me is to write it out you
know you you really just have to
take a complete break uh i don't know i
mean do something else
so fire an alternative profession like
this
yes so you know you find other sources
of income
while you wait for your mind to kind of
clear and then uh and you start again
this is the reason why um there was a um
you know i was working in a big firm
patreon publishing uh as a creative
director for for eight years and
when i stopped uh i was very tired so i
decided to open a bar and art gallery
i think jan was a frequent drinker at my
business
yeah so uh yeah i took a break
and uh and when i was ready i started
the press room great
great great interesting and uh always as
always
humorous response thank you for that
kelly um shall we yeah
there are various various questions and
something that uh
um like talking about the practice and
talking about the influences
uh you've been in the industry for for
some time now
and you've been some evil evolutions in
the trends
uh do you think that there is um a
southeast asian
kind of identity to to your practice
or do you see that they are still um and
they will still
be having any kind of cross-references
between
whatever is happening in the rest of the
world i'm not saying
the west because the rest of the world
is pretty big
so how basically do you deal with this
with this identity from southeast asia
as opposed to the rest of the world and
how does
does this inform your practice
um maybe we can start with yeah on that
oh i
i mean to be honest i don't really think
that
particularly in singapore i don't feel
like we are particularly
trapped in um a style
per se everything comes from a different
source of inspiration and i mean i think
singapore is so smart everyone's been
very exposed to various different
cultures because
i guess because of our geographical
location we do travel
quite a bit and because we are hub we do
get a lot of influences
i don't see i mean i just want to say
for myself i don't see
particularly a huge southeast asian
um influence on
on at least my practice you know yes
there are
times that we had to design something
for a
cultural institution but that's always
resolved with
inspiration i mean using perhaps
materials that were used uh
perhaps traditionally or historically uh
from a certain era
in singapore maybe but that those kind
of
application has always been very
modernized i feel like singapore
maybe is a different sort of environment
that at least for the way i approach
the design it's always something that is
very today as opposed to something that
is
um has a certain sort of uh
cultural or or yeah identity to it
i don't feel like i do that so i'm not
sure of
what who um kelly or william could share
because
like we're very interesting to hear from
what you say
uh from kelly for example you see an
evolution of the style
that our school of thought was
towards experiential design my
physiographic design in southeast asia
is it amazing discipline or is it
something that has been happening for
years and that is strengthening what do
you think of this okay so i
i think um for me right uh the different
disciplines of
design uh is it's the response to
culture is very very different and
and to cultural evolution um so i think
in terms of architecture and in terms of
product
um it's uh the evolution has been very
distinct and very
uh obvious you see uh i'll just kind of
narrow down and maybe focus on singapore
for example like in terms
of uh singapore architecture uh if
if you look at uh in the in the 60s and
70s you know our our pioneering fathers
like
people like william lim and and uh and
tan kwambi and all that they are very
influenced by uh post-modernism
and uh the metabolism movement and all
that it was all very very western you
know
um but if you look at today you know
fast forward to today
uh i i'm very proud that you know
architects are building a very strong
identity for
not just singapore architecture but also
southeast asian architecture i mean look
at uh look at waha i think they are a
very good example
um they are they are really doing very
good sort of tropical sustainable
high-rise architecture and things pretty
amazing music
so i think that is a very distinct voice
of
um singapore tropical salvation
whichever term that you like you know
it's a terminology but
it's very strong and it's very clear in
terms of product design i would i would
like to reference to
say maybe the thai designers you see um
they always have a very distinct voice
in
in their design that this because they
have a lot of craftsmen there
so when they design their products they
could actually tap
into all these available crafts and
craftsmen
in in thailand and whatever they do
because of the craft in it
you it is just southeast asian you see
so back to singapore you see we have
this problem we have no craftsman we
have no natural resources
so it's very hard in terms of product
design to have that kind of voice where
you can easily tap into a kind of a
craft you see so for us we have no no
no choice but to lean into technology
so in terms of product design uh uh we
are more
westernized if you like i mean i don't
like to use that terminology but that's
the closest i can think of i mean
because the the only way we could create
something is using you know
riding on this technology to create and
we do not have any craftsman
then if i zoom in to graphic design you
see it is even tougher right no natural
resources to play with
no craftsman to play with not much of an
evolution i mean our graphic design team
is still quite young right
so that is not you know we are still
building up the history
and we are still building up uh the
culture of graphic design for
for singapore designers and uh but i
think it is
it is slowly evolving i mean uh uh
we have a lot of uh good designers like
uh theseus
we have asylum we have black we have
yaling you know
this i think the voice is slowly
emerging and i think it will only take
time
you know and it needs time for us to
build up a certain identity
and a certain clear distinct uh sort of
voice
in in the graphics area uh the same way
that architecture has achieved
very long answer okay sorry because it
is
it is uh very informative and also to
reflect on
on the the history of the region and to
see like how to embark on the future
which is even more important
in this time in this time of kovid which
is an extraordinary time so it is
important to reflect upon what has been
happening in the past
to embark on towards positive future
um so maybe we can we can run with other
questions here you have a question for
for williams so so probably something
that we're
a lot of questions that we're getting
about this kind of like cultural dealing
with different
competing western uh western sort of
non-non-western
cultures and and what is uh you know
what are some of these
influences what is prevalent what is
dominating what do people
want and what are the trends so the
question for william uh
uh from michael go uh is um
there is a growing trend or should i say
perception that many local clients
prefer to use more western style design
for wayfinding projects
how do we sell them local inspired
concepts and directions and how are you
successful in this direction so maybe
some of the
some of the tips or experience that you
can share uh
with your work about that
um well first of all you can't force um
culture onto a building
uh which is has no connection to it so i
think every project
is quite different and we need to look
at the we need the context of the
project it's history who the cooperation
is then we can apply
accordingly although i have
a long interest and passion in southeast
asian
design i can't really apply to many many
of my
projects because they tend to be modern
and the client expects
a more i would like to say a western
oriented approach
to typography and to you know signage
but i think clients are beginning to
loosen up because every building now
looks alike and um and we are
at a very distinct advantage because a
lot of projects coming to us
are art and culture related so
what i commend for what we do in our
work may not be applicable to other
design firms who are
uh fortunately or unfortunately uh
settled with very very corporate type of
thinking
from the clients you know malaysia
singapore
um so rich and you know the
the dutch were here the spanish were
here the portuguese were here the
long history of uh english colonial uh
government and we got a large community
of
indians chinese malays the engineers
indigenous and the tribal uh tribes from
borneo american clients are now
beginning to realize that we have
achieved
such a rich culture i mean we always had
but they just
realized this is it's incredible to me
um i think one project which was quite
interesting was a
commercial shopping mall in kl uh called
soi wang
and it was the first time ever we
introduced the languages of
borneo into the uh shopping mall the
iban
the diax you know and the so
it was quite an interesting experiment
because
um and i think the opportunity is now
really
um having gone through western education
and having realized how rich this
country
is and for clients to realize that as
well i think
it's going to be a very exciting future
thanks thanks a lot for your answer
william again i'm really really
inspiring uh now we are listening so
much to what you are saying and we are
trying to concentrate on the questions
as well
so maybe we will shift a little bit of
conversation towards
the making of uh of experiential graphic
design and the making of environmental
design
and it's a question to to yelling
how do you see your practice in terms of
project development is it that
way finding environmental graphics
exponential design
should come at the beginning of a
project
or is it that like the way that you have
been practicing so far that it comes
towards the end of a project so
how do you see that at which moment
it should enter in a project
when you say a project um oh sorry to
give a bit more context
like a building like an interior because
you shared with us
uh your your your project
for these offices for example or even
the co-working space
so at which moment of this architectural
project development did you enter into
the project
and did it have an impact on your
creative process for example
and therefore is it better to come at a
very early stage of an architectural
project
or later for us
uh because we do mainly
brand things and it's way finding is
part of
that brand expression right for us
branding is always the first thing that
we have to resolve and
establish before doing anything else
whether it's interior design or
the wayfinding and as for wayfinding um
we uh it's also it's okay to work with
the interior
i could come uh i would say
wayfinding could come later than
interior uh
which is fine sometimes we work with um
projects that's just a standalone
wayfinding project and and and or
interior project
that is also a wayfinding project and
it's always
the you know the the space design that
comes first
you know figuring how you know the flow
is first and
then refining comes later on because
wayfinding is
also something that i guess could sit on
how the narrative of the space could be
eventually so that is kind of
how we work and and if we are doing a
brand
uh brand identity for that project and
obviously
um the dna the narrative um the elements
the inspirations should all come from
that basis
it should inform that thank you yoland
uh yes definitely informative so just
going um moving a bit
uh talking a bit more about the the
narrative and the branding um
uh as part of this wayfinding and
experience making
um how do how do you find emotions
uh affecting the design process
and you know do they do they affect your
design process or do you
implement different strategies to evoke
emotions
in in the visitors in the public that's
visiting these spaces
maybe that's a question that i will ask
kelly
if you have any input um
i think it's a very interesting question
because um
in any sort of design you know um
there are times when you want to evoke
emotions but there are also
times when you you might not want
people to feel so much so um
i suppose in this case the the question
is how do you
evoke emotions right i i think in a in
an exhibition design
uh in order to evoke emotion you really
have to engage the different sensors
it's not just about designing a 2d or an
object you know i think you have to
engage you have used audio you have to
use that's why we also work with like
sound designers and musicians uh it
depends on what is needed
so we will bring in the sound will bring
in the visual will bring
the touch so the touch is also about
designing textures and all that
and also designing the i mean the
overall sort of journey
what do you want them to to feel in each
uh space and all that
so it's uh if you you have to look at it
in multi-dimensional when you want to
evoke emotion in someone because the
human being is a very complex animal
they are you can't just expect to put
one thing and then they
they can feel a lot unless you are maybe
picasso you know
so uh so so yeah so as a designer uh we
we we have to kind of build in layers of
different
emotion to trigger the senses
but even in this beyond emotion
when we see the work of william where
you are introducing
meaningful stories behind the wayfinding
how how much is the content penetration
towards the audiences
have you been able to measure that to
understand like when we see that you are
talking about endangered species for
example that you place in your in your
way finding
um because we believe or maybe people
believe that we're finding should be
just functional okay
go from point a to point b but you are
adding this
layer of education of raising awareness
and as kelly mentioned the emotional
side of it
so is that something that is important
in your in your design and
and that the content penetration the
message penetration towards
the audience it is um
i think the penetration would only be
successful
if we handle the entire project from
start
to end and in some cases like the museum
we do have a certain control um
talking about the uh the panels
where we featured the
characteristics of animals and wwf
and you know responsible palm oil
it has no feedback but you uh you know
um
you a person would read the information
hopefully get
uh gain a better knowledge of it but
there's
no feedback mechanism in those panels
but it was part of the blueprint with
the client that
they would actually execute uh
exhibitions
in collaboration with nature society
malaysia wwf and so on and that's where
the real
response will come from so in the case
where you saw the shopping mall it was
just a trigger
just to increase information but there
was no immediate feedback
for the for the trees the local trees
actually
i was talking to the client that uh it
should be part of the corporate
literature
where they could uh uh produce a leaflet
at the time
there weren't many websites this was a
long time ago just to educate people and
just to expand on the
the beauty of trees and descriptions
even more as part of the
corporate philosophy and corporate
literature and i think that would be
successful but in many cases actually
these are executed by the advertising
agency
of which we got no control but
but that was a 1985 and now we have
actually much more control over projects
with our clients so i think it's a
matter of
how much are you in charge of the entire
project from start to a
and beyond where you can actually
determine whether the messages have
actually gone true to the audience we
intended to
okay i think thanks a lot i think we we
are we are reaching almost the end of
the
of the third week we we can have a one
concluding
question to each of you uh because these
are questions that have been coming back
especially towards younger audiences
what would be your concluding note
to motivate and inspire young designers
to continue in this field of
experiential
uh design a motive design
immersive environmental design
so what could be your your final address
to
to the younger audiences to motivate
them towards this profession or even how
how do you start in this profession
because i think there's there's a lot of
uh
still mystique about it like what what
should you do
how do i get into it what what can i do
to be better to be
uh to be one of you guys essentially so
i think we'll
we'll take it uh around the around the
circle so kelly do you have any advice
for the
up-and-coming future designers
um okay so i think in terms of
wave finding and and exhibition graphics
uh
it's um if you want to to go into this
field i think you
you have to be a little bit all-rounded
because you must understand
spaces you must understand graphic and
not just
like illustration or something you you
need to understand type
you need to understand the proportion of
type in space
not just on a piece of paper you need to
understand content you need to
you need to understand what storytelling
is you see
you need to understand how to use
multimedia or interactive not just a
touch screen uh
so i mean there's a lot of uh there's a
lot of things you you have to learn and
of course
unfortunately not any university can
provide this kind of all-rounded kind of
education
so uh so my advice is that you know if
you are studying a kind of a design
discipline
uh fret not i mean it doesn't matter
whether you're
you know studying graphic design you're
studying architecture or whatever
uh when you graduate i mean try to try
to
learn try to learn in a company you know
humble yourself and be an intern or find
a mentor
work in a company and it's only it's
really true
experience you really have to have to go
through the journey
and uh do a few projects you know
uh then you can really feel what works
what doesn't and
and then you also know your weaknesses
uh what area you need to polish up on
what area you might need to
uh take up a course you know that's why
lifelong learning right
so uh i think even for i mean even for
me
every day i'm learning something like
when i i think one of the
best way to learn is really to to visit
uh you know
museums and places uh in nice beautiful
places in the world
i mean now it's colbit but before that i
travel a lot every country i go to i'll
make sure to go to all the museums and
that is the best source of of
inspiration and also the best place
for me to learn as well to open up my
eyes and to say hey i like this why do i
like this i don't like this why do i
uh not like this uh so on and so forth
yeah
so i think uh it's it's really about
yeah finding the right place to learn
and then uh looking at things and if all
else fail you need inspiration you can
you know yeah so that's my advice
i also have my eye
on the desk
by the side here
[Music]
do you have a concluding address to the
younger audience
i think kelly said it most uh already
but i just wanted to add that yes
there's no shortcut and
definitely find your way into a good
design studio that
you should learn from because it's not
something that you
would know or be able to do right away
um there needs to be passion and
i guess it's not going to be easy
because
design is not just about designing it's
also managing the
client managing the projects and
managing the contractors
there's a lot of human management at um
at that level and that's something that
designers forget or that they don't know
about so this
is something that's real and uh that
could be
something that um you can
learn or experience when you work at
some place
and the passion part is important if
you're someone who is
very driven by design as well as
the fact that you could make someone um
live better or you know find a way
better or you know have a
better life in a building a home
um generally making an
impact with design then yeah that's
something for you
i don't think anyone is for design or
uh wayfinding designers uh you know
particular but
refining is is not uh
like just sitting in front of a computer
computer like what kelly has described
is
you have to make sure that it's readable
it's it's it's it's very physical
um it's more than it's more than
designing on a computer
so yeah it takes patience it takes
tenacity it takes
determination and passion and knowing
checking the reality that it's not just
design but also
managing the different uh people that
you need to deal with
in the project yeah but then thank you
for showing that
thank you and and william what what
would be your words of wisdom
for the up-and-coming designers yeah um
well the two things i think travel is
important
travel and talk to people i'm not sure
the value of selfies
you know in the uk in the old days even
though you may have graduated
from cambridge or oxford you are not
considered educated
until you take the grand european tour
to really see the world
and i think you can find a lot of
inspiration by traveling
and talking to people looking at
communities how they see
things understand different perspectives
and of course most important for young
people going into the industry is
of course passion not only passion for
design but
past your own personal passion or liking
or interest in something it could be
sports it could be art and culture it
could be
flowers it could be toys because the
field is wide enough
for you to enter into this specialized
areas which
really really you are interested in and
if you really are
interested in you will be definitely
successful
thanks uh thanks for for this very
profound message so
i will be wrapping up the day so i mean
not the day the
the talk uh so we'll be having a few
last slide
before we because we close up but before
we share with you how to reach out to
scgd
how to give feedback and also how to
connect uh to dsg because we will be
sharing that uh for the
last seven we haven't said goodbye yet
to our speakers so speakers please stay
say
before we say goodbye but if you want to
know more about scgd
you can sign up for membership on that
link you can visit the scgt website
and of course you can find out more
about the scgdd singapore chapter
by reaching out to hola and myself
and and and also i just want to say
goodbye to the
to the speakers before we hand over to
dsg for the last qr code
uh so thanks an immense thanks
to kb yelling william it's a pleasure
to have you today uh very inspiring very
interesting
um and highly motivating towards
this specific discipline that is uh
experiential graphic design so thanks a
lot
we hope that it has inspired all of our
audience thanks a lot
yes yes thank you from all of us
and and for your your tireless
dedication and thank you for joining us
uh because we have way too many
questions and we're we're sorry we
didn't have
too much we would have been here for
hours and hours with all the questions
uh
if we uh where to answer all the
questions but uh
uh you know find out about uh scgdd
uh email us uh get in touch uh uh
get on our email list because we will be
having these
informative talks uh about crafting
experiences and about all of the
disciplines uh of the experiential
graphic design because as we
as we know this it's not just your
traditional sort of field it's
it's it involves a lot of disciplines
and a lot of it
and it comes people come from all walks
of life so
we definitely i think we are happy
and we're going to continue this
conversation through this year
and also emotive design also it is uh
the month
in design singapore uh so
we'll be uh sharing with you the qr code
after saying goodbye to everyone
um so thanks again kelly yelling and
william
for your presence today thank you thank
you very much
thanks a lot and to our audience please
stay on board because you can scan the
qr code to give feedback
and also to continue uh with design
singapore for emotive design in march
2021
thanks everyone charlotte over to you
for the qr code
you